service level objectives or slos are the
primary way by which we set appropriate
reliability targets for our services
the latest release of slo monitoring in
google cloud operations
makes doing this especially easy for
services running on gke i'm here today
to give you a walk through and show you
how to get started
this is the stackdoctor
[Music]
we looked at how to use the api to
define service level indicators or slis
and set slos in an earlier episode
but now you can do both of those in the
ui let's take a look
start by going to the services screen
under monitoring if you're using the
istio service mesh in your cluster
you'll notice that your services have
already been automatically identified
for you
you can filter the list as necessary for
example you may
want to only see services running on the
particular cluster or in the particular
region
to filter for services that match a
particular label value just type the
value of the label you want into the
filter field
if you're not using istio you can define
a new service by selecting a gk entity
you'd like to use as the base for the
service
this won't make any modifications of the
entity itself it'll just create a new
monitoring construct you can use to
create
slos once you've found the service
you're looking for or created a new one
click on it in the list on the service
details screen you can see the slos
you've already defined for it if they're
already
any alerts for the time span selected
and the logs for the service
from here click create a seller
in order to create an slo you first have
to choose the sli or the service level
indicator you'd like to use as the
measure service reliability
here you have three options availability
performance or other
but what does each one of those mean an
availability sli will measure the ratio
of successful requests
to all requests to the service for this
service issue automatically tracks that
metric and no additional instrumentation
is necessary
a performance sli will measure the ratio
of requests that complete within a
specific time to all requests
because istio automatically tracks
latency for each request this is another
out-of-the-box metric
if you only use a custom metric as your
sli select other at this point
for example you may have instrumented
the service using open telemetry to
count the number of transactions that
meet specific criteria
and using a custom sli will let you
select that metric
the next choice is between a request
based and a window-based sli
we covered this in our earlier episode
on using the api to create our slos but
it's worth reviewing it briefly
request based slis measure the fraction
of good units of work against the total
for example what percentage of requests
your service were successful in a given
time window
an example of a request based
availability slo is
99 of requests are successful over a
rolling seven-day window
this is the more straightforward and
commonly used option
window-based slis measure the fraction
of time intervals during which the
service meets some threshold
over a given time window an example of a
window-based availability slo is
99 of requests are successful within 99
of 10-minute intervals
over a rolling seven-day window once
you've selected your sli and evaluation
type click next
take a look at the signal you've chosen
and confirm that the metric behaves as
you would expect
for example if the service has been
healthy for the last hour the metric
should show a mostly flat trend
once you're satisfied with the signal
click next
you may recall that an slo is the
combination of three things the sli
which we've already chosen a target and
a compliance period
on this screen you need to provide the
compliance period which is the length of
the time window over which the sli is
going to be evaluated
next specify your goal this is the
target for the sli
now your slo definition is complete
click next to finalize it
this is the last step give your slo a
name that reflects what it's measuring
and click submit that'll take you back
to the service details screen with your
new slo
added and its health clearly displayed
thanks for joining me today
we'll look at the new slo monitoring
functionality and learn how to use it to
define availability and performance slos
for our services running in gke
now you are ready to start configuring
slos for your own services
thanks for watching and come back soon
for more this is the stackdoctor
stay healthy out there